Gary what were you yapping about with
John hind this morning so the playoffs
of this week it's the NFL playoffs so
one of the uh um playoff games is going
to be behind a pay wall on peacock and
what we were saying is there's a lot of
guys on the show who bought NFL Sunday
Ticket it's like 350 bucks which gets
you all the regular season games but I
don't know if you pay 350 bucks for
football you think they'd give you the
playoff games but now they're across a
bunch of different Networks and this one
is the first time ever you have to pay
and people are flipping out so what are
you guys doing are you signing up for
that game or are you going to I already
I already have it I already I already
have it I pay for it you paid I get I
get everything I just get everything you
know what I think's funny will told me
he's been begging JD for his peacock
password and JD won't give it to him
because he's afraid he get in
trouble so Will's like arrested and
thrown into peacock jail yeah Will's
trying to bully JD into getting his
peacock password yeah it's nice to
finally have some power you better give
me that password that's what I want it's
prob nice to have some power over uh Mr
M when did you when did you start uh
working him for the P I started text
well I begged a lot of people nobody
would give it to me and then I last
night I was like oh JD I bet he has he
watches everything so I started you know
sweet talking to him but so far he's a
fight I just wrote
maybe what's your hesitation giv bre
down you're breaking down what's your
hesitation in giving Will the password
are you afraid that like um peacock will
find out and take I think I think it's
more the password
for password for that is like the
password for like
other so I think I can't remember what
my password is but uh that's my that's
my main worry otherwise you know what
the you know what actually I am kind of
worried of him like messing up my
algorithm or something Jes like I could
see him like trying to [__] with me and
going through my profile and like
watching all this [__] and [__]
everything up I just want to watch the
game get in his bank account no big
deal